ではなんか七十七ページの十四番目の
えーと 紋による心の分別はなんか飛び出したみたいですけど
七十六ページのところから飛び込んで七十八
だからどちらが飛んじゃったんですか
七十六と七十七で七十八の最初のところ
番号では十一 あの十一はやってない
七十六ページの頭のところをやらないと
そこはいいです で まあいいよ
どこでも じゃあ七十六
七十六ページの十一 あの
まあちょっと見てください
やたあさく ちっときっけがななという
各心における作用の個数と
まあていすぱなドゥエうぺっかさほどさんていらなちったーにぱちさんびばわんがちゅちただらんまん
なさんていらなわせえなぱんちきっちゃんに名目というのがありまして
で ここで言ってるのは
で 心 一つの心がどれぐらいの仕事をしているんですかということなんです
で まあ今まで説明した心の
まあ分析がありまして
その各心が何か仕事をするんですね
その仕事の仕事は全部十四種類しかないんですけど
そこでこのドゥエうぺっかさほどさんていらなちったーに
あの あの水道心という心が二つありまして
舎利的の水道心は二つあるんですね
それは十八のカテゴリーに入ってるんですね
十八の無因心の中に入ってるんです
で 舎利的の水道心二つ
その心二つはもうかなり仕事をするんですね
どういう仕事というと
まあ結晶 いわゆる生まれ変わること
その働きをする で 生まれ人が
まあ生命が新しく生まれたら
確実に同じ心がその生命のうぶんの働きするんですね
いわゆる存在としてつなげてくれる働きもその同じ心がするんです
ですから あの結晶の作用したら確実にうぶんの作用もする
そうすると その生命が死ぬ時も
その同じ心で最後のが終わっちゃうんですね
最後の心として同じ心が生まれるんです
ですから死心も死の作用も同じ心なんですね
ですから いつでも結晶うぶん死というのは三つの仕事なんですけど
同じ心がするっていうことを覚えておいてください
この二つの射具の水道心はその三つの仕事をする
その上へあの非正縁という仕事あるんですね
それはパーリ語だったら
まあただアランマナ ただアランマナっていうのはまあ説明しただろうと思いますけど
まあ後でそれはまあいくらか説明いたしますから
次の章に入ったら説明しますから
あの で 何か認識したところで
その認識か認識したものをまあわずかに味わうような感じなんですね
その瞬間で で それをまあそれぐらいの理解で結構だと思います
で 次の章に入ったら このもっと詳しく説明します
で それでこのこれ可笑縁非正縁
非正縁と書いてますから
まあ漢字ではなかなか意味通らないかもしれませんだけど
まあ同じ対象を認識するという意味なんですね
ですからこの 別にまあただ
例えば目で何か見たら
この見たものは全部認識して終わって
もうちょっと同じ対象に据えてるんですね
で それどのようなことかと理解をすると
まあまあ我々は例えば何かもう大胆な経験があった時は
ものすごい大胆なものを見てしまったとかね
で 見て終わっても なんとなく心に残っているような感じがするんですね
その見たものを また何か残っていると
なんかすごい音を聞いたら
ものすごい面白い音を初めて聞いたらすごくびっくりしたりするし
それで音終わってもなんとなくもうちょっと残っているという感じがあるんですね
そのような働きなんですね
ですから 味わうということ
結果が受けるということなんですね
別にまあそれぐらいの心で
別に大したカルマになるわけでも何でもないんです
それはこの非正縁という働き
一つの働きなんです 仕事なんです
非正縁と それからスヴィドという働きもこのまあ心がする
だからスヴィドーシンだからスヴィドという働きするのは当たり前なんですね
で サンティルナっていうのは何かこの
まあ区別するような まあどっちにしようかというふうな
わかる 分かれる 分かれて
まあ分ける仕事なんですね
だから大体は我々体に触れる対象
眼耳鼻舌身意に触れる対象は
いいものか悪いものかという判断できるんですね
その判断の場合は 例えば私にとっていいものだ
でも人にとってはそれは悪いものだというふうな判断ではないんです
それはあくまでもあの心理の世界の判断なんです
ということは 例えばあるものを見て
私はすごく喜びを感じる
他の人はそのものを見て全く喜びを感じない
ですから 私の水道心がそれは楽だと判断したのではないかと
相手の水道心はそれは苦だと判断したのではないかというふうに思うかもしれません
でも そういうことは言ってるわけじゃないんです
で ここで うーん ある法則として何か決まってるみたいですね
ですから 例えば善に判断するものは
誰の心でも善に判断するんだと
悪として悪い結果として判断するものは
どんな生命にしたっても
そのように判断してしまうということを言いたがっているんですね
アビダンマでは で それに具体的な例で考えちゃうと分かりやすいんです
で 仏教の話なんですけど
仏教では人が何か見ると
まあ欲か怒りか 無知かどっちか生まれちゃうんです
何か見ると それでいわゆる貪瞋痴か浮貪浮瞋痴か
この六つのどこかに入っちゃうんですね
そこで仏像を見たんだと
仏像を見た時は確実に浮貪浮瞋浮痴の心が生まれるんだと
決まってるんです で それでその仏像でも仏画でもいいし
まあ仏様のお釈迦様の絵を見たと
あるいは仏像を見たんだと
その時はその人の心に善心が生まれるんだと
確実に水道心はそれは善果として判断しちゃうんだと
じゃあそれだったら まあキリスト教の人が仏像を見ちゃったら
ものすごく腹が立ってしまうんではないかと
そうするとキリスト教の人にとって仏像を見ると不善心生まれるんではないかと
そこで注釈僧で まあキリスト教という言葉はないんだけど
まあ当時なかったんだから
邪教という言葉が出てきますけど
で まあ邪教の邪教を信じている人も
仏像を見たらそれはしょうがないんだと
その人にはその瞬間で善心が生まれるんだと
それで後で自分で考えたところで
その対象について腹が立ったり
怒ったり いろんなことしたり
それは後の話ですと 見た瞬間で心には貪瞋痴は生まれるはずがないんだと
で その例で まあ全くその通りであるかどうかわかりませんだけど
その例でこのブッダガヤ長老はこのあんまりこの普遍的な科学的な説明は全くしていないんだから
そこで科学的に言いたがっているのは
この対象が体に触れたら起こる反応は決まっているということなんです
違う例で見れば すごい冷たい風が体に触れたら
ああ気持ちいいと思うはずがないんです
なぜなら我々の体には体温というのは決まってあって
それは奪うような この体温がさっとたくさん外へ奪われるとということになりますから
すごい冷たい風が吹いたら
もう我慢する人も 我慢できない人も
ああ 冷たくて気持ちいいという人にとっても
事実として結果は同じなんです
体の体温が奪われたことなんですね
それは避けられない 例えば
もう冷たい風が気持ちいいと思う人に
冷たい風が体に触れると
体に温度が熱が入ることはありますかね？ありえないんです
その人の場合も 熱が出ることは科学的な事実なんですね
ですから 我々は後でどう考えたっても
それは後の話で この対象が触れた瞬間では具体的に判断するんだと
ありのまま判断するんですね
そのありのままの判断は水道心がしちゃうんです
そのありのままでない判断は
心で勝手に後でするんです
そういうことで 音があの耳に触れても同じことで
で 眼耳鼻舌身に触れる色声香味何とか何とか
もうパーリ語でしか言いにくいんだけど
いわゆるループサッブカンダラスポッタープダッマという６つの対象がありましてね
色と声とね 味 味とか香りとか
そういう対象６つ決まってるんだから
その対象はまあいくらかは５つは物質的なものでしょうし
目に入るものは物質であって
耳に触れるものは物質であって
鼻に触れるものは物質あって
体に舌に触れるものは物質ですね
それで心に触れるものは物質で
ある場合もあるし ない場合もあるということで
いわゆる心には過去現在未来のどんなものでも触れることはできますと
という決まりなんです
あるものもないものも心には触れるんだと
でも耳目には実際にあるものしか触れません
だから目で見えるのは現在のみ
耳で聞こえるのは現在のみ
心だけだったら過去のことを思うこともできるし
まあ将来のことを思うこともできるし
ありくはないことも考えたりすることはできますね
で 心の働きはすごく多いんだから
我々はいつでも妄想の中にいるということなんですけど
全部つなげて頭で考えちゃいますからね
例えば言葉っていうのは音にないんですね
私は喉から何か音を作ってるだけ
それは言葉にするのは我々の頭の中なんですね
ですから 私は言葉を流してるんですか？というのは
全然言葉を流してるわけじゃないんです
体という機械から音を作っているだけなんです
それで聞く方 相手方は
まあそれは言葉にする
それはもう心の働きで
だから結局は実際しない言葉が心の中であるのように思ってしまうんですね
ですから ないものでも心には認識できる
私たちには 例えば人を見ましたと言ったって人を見えないんです
目には人が入りませんだからね
目にはいつでも同じもの
科学的に言えば同じ光の波動が触れるだけなんです
それ触れる光の波動によって人が見た牛が見たサンタさんが見たとか
なんとかは言えます それは心がもうないものを作るんですね
じゃあないものは作ると言っても
私はサンタさんが見たと言ったら
次の人も え？私はサンタさんじゃなくて
あの 何て言うのか 東京タワー見たよって言わないんです
こちらサンタさんがいるよと私は言ったならば
まあそうですねと隣にいる人を言うんです
それはどういうことかというと
それは今言ってる水道心の働きなんですね
だから心は勝手に妄想するのはもう構いませんだけど
それほど勝手にも妄想できないんですね
サンタさん 私はサンタさんだと判断した対象を
他の人が東京タワーだ
違います それは東京タワーだとは言わないんです
ちょっと言葉を変えて
それはサンタさんじゃなくてサンタの格好をしている人やと言うかもしれませんだけど
それでも別に大した差がないんですね
そこら辺ですね この水道心のこの働きで言いたがっているのは
こので判断はするんだけど
判断は心に勝手にもできますけど
それ完璧に心に勝手に判断をまた変えてできない
で 普遍的な法則で決まられているんですね
ですから あの 誰の体にも冷たい風が触れちゃったら
あ 嫌という感じが生まれるんです
その時は あの 不善意熟心の水道心が生まれるんです
で それはまあしょうがないんです
決まってるんです ですから
この水道心にはもう大変な我々よりなんかすごい
すごい仕事あるんです
いわゆる事実をありのまま判断することだから
判断というほどじゃないんだけど
ありのまま決まってしまう
それから我々は心の中で
まあ好き勝手にいろんなことをやって
苦しみの世界を作ると
で まあ例えば冷たい風
まあ触れたんだと それはまあ嫌と
それで別に問題はないんです
暖かい空気触れたら あ
気持ちいいと それは別に問題ないんです
問題はそれから生まれるんです
それからいかに心が働くかということによって問題が生まれるんです
ということは お釈迦様は悟っているんだと
悟っていたんだから お釈迦様の体に針を刺されたんだと
お釈迦様はもう悟ってるんだから
ものすごく気持ちいいんだということにならないんです
お釈迦様の体にも針を刺されたならば痛いんです
痛いというのは善意熟心ではなくて
不善意熟心なんです ですから
お釈迦様の体に針で刺された時も
お釈迦様の水道心が不善意熟心なんです
不善意熟の  遮蔽の水道心なんです
それは法則ですから で
問題はそれからなんですね
お釈迦様がそこで止まるんですね
針が刺されて あ 痛かったと
それっきりもう何も妄想が動かないんですね
で 普通我々の場合は もう刺された人に対して
なんであなたもうそんなことをするんですかとか
いろんな世界を作っちゃうんですね
そこでまあ違う世界が生まれてくる
この生まれてくる違う世界は人間が勝手に作る世界であって
法則の世界ではないんだと
だから法則の世界に戻っちゃえば
もう何のこともない 誰でも同じなんです
この水道心二人 二つはもう五つの仕事をとにかくするんです
で 決勝 それからウブン
それからシッというセットの仕事と
えーと カショエンという仕事と水道の仕事
じゃあヒショウエンですね
いつでもカーと読むんです
なんででしょうかね 頭の中でインプットしている
これ直らないんです ヒショウエンですね
カショエンではなく  だから決まってるんですかって聞いてる
そこら辺の読み方っていうのは別にね
わからないんですね まあ仏教用語と言ったって
これはクシャロンにあるんだったらもう読み方がね
判断できますけどね そうすると日本の伝統だから
この風に読みましょうと決まりがあるんだけど
これはまあ読み方はどうでもいいんですかって
だからそういう決まりにはならないんで
これもどうせ初期仏教
まあテーラワーダのことを強引に訳したものだから
読み方っていうのはまあ決まってないんだけど
まあ普通でいいと思いますけどね
正しい読み方あるかないかというのは
やっぱりクシャロンでも探してみなきゃちょっとわからないし
今はちょっとテキストはないし
まあ読み方だからそれは私に関係ないです
私には関係ない あまり私が間違って発音しちゃうと
まあ皆様困りますからね
そこら辺ちょっと気をつけなくちゃいけない
自分がそれだけ まあそういうその五つの働きをする
それからマハー・ヴィパーカ・チッタというやつはあります
マハー・ヴィパーカっていうのは
この大神二十四の中に八種類が意熟心として出てくるんですね
この意熟心の大神 大意熟心八
その八が決勝とウブンとシッとこの
飛翔縁という仕事はするんです
仕事４つですね 心は強くなると何か仕事が少なくなっちゃうんです
あの水道心っていうのはすごい弱い心なんです
すごい弱い心はもう５つの仕事しちゃうし
この意熟心っていうのはもう大意熟心っていうのはかなり強い心なんです
でも仕事は４つしかしないんです
で それから次に出てくるのは
この十一のススキなんですが
このマハッガタ・ヴィパーカーニ
マハッガタ・ヴィパーカっていうのは
マハー・ヴィパーカ マハー・ヴィパーカどういう訳ですかっけ
大意熟心 マハッガタもまた大意熟心と訳してるんだから
これ困っちゃった この次にこのマハッガタ・ヴィパーカ
またこのテキストではまたそれも大意熟心と書いて括弧の中で上二界と書いてますから
で その場合はこの禅定の世界ですね
だからマハー・ヴィパーカ
マハッガタ・ヴィパーカとパーリ語ではちょっと区別してるんです
マハー・ヴィパーカというのは大意熟心
マハッガタっていうのは偉大
大なる状態になったという意味なんですね
ですから色界の心５つと無色界の心は４つと９つあるんです
まあそれは禅定の世界ですね
だから禅定を作った方々の場合は
禅定の心は９つありますし
そちらの意熟心の場合は決勝有分心しかやらないんですね
仕事は で 次にあのまた水道心に戻っちゃうんです
で 水道心は３つあるんですね
舎宮の２つと器宮の１つと
この舎宮の２つの中で １
つはあの不善意熟心 １
つは善意熟心 器宮の水道心はあの善意熟心です
この器宮の 器宮と言うんでしょうか
どっちでしょう 器宮の水道心はどんな仕事をしますかというと
まあ水道の仕事とこの飛翔縁の仕事って２つするんですね
まああの そんなに難しくない
今はちょっとなんかちょっと混乱状態であるかもしれませんだけど
それはまあ後ですぐわかると思います
[咳]それから次にこの一番難しくややこしいのはこの十八の無因心なんですね
ですから このアビダンマをちゃんと理解したければ
十八の無因心を徹底的に覚えておいた方がいいんです
別に覚えにくいわけでもない
それはパーリ語で覚えておいた方がもう結構わかりやすいので
いつでもそこら辺はものすごくもう不別大きくてガタガタしているんです
他の心はそんなに難しくはないんです
決まってるんだから 善果悪果と
この十八の無因心っていうのは
この心理学的な作用するのはそこだけなんです
だからいつでも使わなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる認識過程で誰にでも起こる普通の機能はそこにひ入ってますから
先悪と関係なく そこら辺を覚えておけば問題ないと思いますけど
その十八の水道心の中にこの確定心というものが出てくるんですね
これパーリ語でウォッタッペナ
あるいはこっちはウォッタッベナと書いてますけど
ピもビも大体似ていますから
ウォッタッベナあるいはウォッタッペナチッタンという心なんですね
確定する ですから この見たものをいいものか悪いものかとちょっと決めて
それからこういうものだと確定しちゃうんですね
そういうのは自然な流れでも
我々にとっては 個人にはどうすることもできない
いわゆる針が体に刺されたらもう痛い
それはもうどうすることもできないんです
そこで不善意熟心やと
水道心がそれは射具の何と言います
射具の水道心だと その射具の水道心が生まれるではなくて
射具の水道心生まれたら次に確定心が生まれる
だから確定心はもう同じなんです
いわゆる水道心の次 必ずしも確定心が生まれる
それ確定心が確定する仕事と
因天の作用二つするんですね
因天っていうのはこの
どういう仕事かな 心 例えば目に情報入ったら心が目に行っちゃう
耳に音が触れると心が耳に行ってしまっちゃう
そういう風に我々の意識がこの適当な場所に走っちゃうんです
走ってその認識をこの情報を受け取る
ですから 現に身心に走る心には五門因天というんです
心の中で対象が現れるたびにすかまる
現れるたびにすかまる心には五門因天というんですね
ですから パンチャドワラワッジナ
マノドワラワッジナと二つあるんですけど
そこでこのウォッタプナチットも因天の作用するんだということを言ってるんです
一つ質問してもいいですか
はい  因天は善と悪ではないんですよね
え？ 因天心は善と悪ではないんですよね
ない ない  それで五識になった段階で善か悪かどっちかになるんですよね
意熟か悪意熟かね  悪意熟か決まるんですね
そしたら水道と あ 領受と水道もそれと同じで善と悪になるんですよね
途中で脱線して善と悪が変わったりはしないんですよね
例えば心識が以前の痛みだったのが
領受と水道も善か不善か同じになるんですよ
その三つは 五識と領受と心場っていうのは全部同じ
三つとも同じになる 善だったら善
悪だったら  うん だからこちらカテゴリーに入れてるでしょ
そのカテゴリーから外れない
行ったり来たりはしない
ないんです うん だから例えば先意熟心の場合は
水道心 あの 何？そうそう
領受心 出動心 入ってるんだからね
その三つは全部善だったら善で
ですから分けてるんです
分けてないのはこの最後のあの最後ではなく
十八の最後に出てくる指差心三つなんですね
そちらには五門陰天と異門陰天がありまして
そちらには善も悪もないんです
いわゆる情報がどこから来るかと見ているだけで
それで情報を取ったら
それから判断すると そこで善か悪かになってしまっちゃうんです
その三つは判断なし  その三つには善悪判断はなし
だから指差心というのは
善でもない 悪でもない心はいつでも指差心と書いているんですね
ただ仕事をするのみ 働きのみと
それで仕事を一つだけする心がまた次に並べているんですね
で 残り心は全部仕事を一つ一つするんだという話で
で まあ仕事はもうジャワネスという職業という作用と
マノーダハトッティカっていうのは
あの 五門陰天と異門陰天と覚定心ですけど
日本語を使うと私も結構混乱します
パーリ語だけだったら
じゃああの この十三は言ったと
言ったでしょうね まあそこら辺は別にやらなくたっていいところだから
そこでどこで飛んだんですか？この前
うん まあドア それから七十七ページの四番目のドアラなんです
ドアラ と まあそれは説明したと思いますけど
ドアラっていうのは心が現れるドア
門という意味なんですね
どんな どんな門で心が現れる
門は六つですから まあそれは眼耳鼻舌身意なんですね
だからその仕事によって言葉変える
この場合は眼門 鼻門 耳門
鼻門 舌門とか何とか読むだろうと思いますけど
そういう風に門入れちゃいますね
パーリ語だったら必ず門入れちゃいますね
チャックドア ソータドア
ガーナドア ジワドア カーヤドア
マノドアと うん まあそれも一つの仏教の世界で
まあ例えば眼耳鼻舌身意とも一つで決めつけるんではなくて
眼耳鼻舌身意がそのいろんな仕事をするんだから
仕事ごとにその言葉を変えちゃうんですね
ですから 眼だけではなくて
門入れちゃえば情報が入る入り口という意味をするんです
その仕事で使う場合は必ずそのチャックドアと言わなくちゃいけない
それから界 ダートという言葉も使う時もありますし
チャックダート あの眼耳鼻
眼と書いて界と書くんですね
世界の界 その場合は違う働きを考えているんですね
ですから もうまあ眼と言っても
眼門と言っても 眼界と言ったって全く同じものを三つの言葉入れてうるさいという意味ではなくて
三つの立場で三つの定義はそこで三つの仕事を考えているんです
眼耳鼻舌身意と言えば
単なる一般的な言葉だけで何も意味をしないんですね
で 具体的に意味をするためには
それにもう一つ一つ言葉を付け加えなくちゃいけない
そういうことで用語は増やしてはいくんです
増やすんだけど 同じ用語を繰り返すようにもなるんですね
じゃあ心が現れる場所が六つありますということで
次にドアラチッタいばく
どんな門でどんな心が生まれるかと
ということで あの だからこっち眼が眼門であると
チャックがチャックドアであると
まあそこら辺わかりやすいし
そこで耳が うん その門になっちゃうし
耳門になっちゃうし 鼻が鼻門になっちゃうし
そういう風になって じゃあ意門って何ですかと
そこら辺でも覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる意門の場合はウブンが意門になると
そこが大事なポイントなんです
ウブンっていうのはバワンガチってウブンシンなんですね
だからウブンっていうのは前も説明しましたから
人が見たり聞いたり何もしない瞬間
いわゆる生命として何も仕事をしない時は
この生命とつなげてる
それでも 死んだわけじゃないんですね
何も見てない 聞いてない
味わってない瞬間で 人考えてもない瞬間の人が死んだことにはならないんですね
それだったらね 麻酔なんかかけちゃったら人が死んだことになりますから
夢も見ないんだからね
もう完全に麻酔かけたところで
でも人は死んだわけじゃないんです
その時も心がちゃんと働いてはいるんです
その時はただどこか情報を受け取れるところまで一応つなげてはいるんです
心は生滅 生滅 生滅しながら
その心にウブンと言うんですね
だからウの働きするブブンという意味なんです
ウブンっていうのはバワアンガだから
バワっていうのは生きてること
アンガっていうのはつなげてくれるという
あの部品というね という意味で
ですから まあ日本語でもウブンではいいかもしれませんし
で そこで我々はこの何か考える時
このウブンシンが門になっちゃうんですね
ウブンシンが変えちゃって
考え方が生まれちゃうんです
いわゆる仏教  意門は何役かやってるってこと？